[Music]
welcome to the
my the minor spoilers show i'm your host
paul aka
four inches long cut or uncut but we're
not going to get into that
what we are going to talk about though
is zack snyder's justice league
which i got to check out over the
weekend i've now watched the film twice
and that sort of gives an inkling to how
how i feel about it you know what
would i go back and watch your four-hour
film twice in a row
if it wasn't good well we'll talk about
it however i just want to preface this
video by saying
there will be some minor spoilers here
hence the name change
and basically if you watch the trailers
or the 2017 theatrical cut
you probably have a fair idea of what's
going on
now the skeletons of that story you know
this structure of it
that's still basically within that film
so things like steppenwolf's plan
which characters come back and so on
they're all present in this movie so i
will be touching upon them
and if you don't want anything ruined if
for some reason you've managed to avoid
justice league completely
then get the hell out of here now thanks
for sticking around
i'm talking to you and the first thing
you probably want to know is
is this better than justice league
absolutely
it completely washes it away it gets
that bad taste out your mouth
and this is definitely the canon version
of the film that we should have got in
the first place
i think warner brothers recognized their
error and they
put this out and now we can finally have
it and just be like
this is amazing but also why the hell
didn't you release this in the first
place
i'm so glad that i don't have to stare
at henry cavill's face doing
doing this as he's talking and just
looking so stupid
because that movie was so bad and you
know what
the crazy thing is i actually bought it
twice i bought the blu-ray yeah
and i kept the slip case and i got the
4k as well
and uh yeah gonna gonna throw that away
now that
don't need that anymore because we've
got a much better version so
is it better than justice league
absolutely
now this video i'm gonna be talking
about the good
the bad and things i'm sort of unsure
of now i have spent eight hours with
this film but there are still
little nitpicks and things i think you
know
might either get to me or i might think
uh you know i don't care
we'll discuss all that at the end though
i just want to talk about the positives
of this film straight off the bat
and that is the just from the opening
it is already better than justice league
now the way that the zack snyder trilogy
worked
especially with this movie is you
realize all of these movies completely
interconnect with one another for
example man of steel
the fighting metropolis you can watch
that film turn it off
pick a bbs put it in and you get the the
perspective of bruce wayne
that sort of happens with this film and
it ties in very
very well with the ending of batman v
superman and sort of recontextualizes
the events that happened in that
to build upon this story and set it up
the way that i would describe it is
just in the same way that the two towers
opened where you saw an event happen and
then went with gandalf
and saw what he got up to that basically
happens in this film not to that extent
action-wise
but they do a very very good job of just
allowing you to finish batman v
superman and then put this disc in or
start hbo max i'm sorry i'm very
physical media
now because of this you're gonna
instantly recognize how tonally
different that this movie is
the best way that i could describe it is
that if you had
if you had a script for a comic book and
you gave that script to two different
artists
they'd both come back with something
that's along the same lines but
one would be totally different to the
other and be and that that is basically
how this film feels it does touch a lot
on the same story beats
but one of these versions completely
mishandled them putting stupid corny
jokes about aliens probing
people and brunch and stuff like that
and this kind of
doesn't do that and therefore it's a lot
better another comparison that i'd make
is i'd say
justice league feels like a movie
whereas this feels like a film
it's very earnest at points they take
the material seriously
it's not just kind of mocking themselves
and you know going look how stupid this
is
it's very very very earnest and because
of that it carries a lot of angst with
it
but you know you really appreciate how
seriously that they're taking this and
when they're not making stupid jokes it
also allows the material itself to
elevate
so you get a lot of epicness to the film
i think the phrase
lord of the rings is gonna be used a lot
when people describe this movie
and it definitely feels that in terms of
scale now off the bat they removed that
terrible rooftop scene as well
and bruce doesn't learn about the mother
boxes or anything from an exploding
parademon who
thanks for leaving that clue behind
massively helped us out to guess that
you were invading instead a lot of the
um exposition comes from diana who she
goes on a quest to kind of discover the
ins and outs of darkseid
and then she relays that information and
it just makes more sense
in general the way that the film works
is that every single scene builds upon
the last
and because of this you have a
continuous momentum throughout the film
where it's all building towards a point
whereas justice league i feel like you
could have reordered a lot of those
scenes and
they probably still would have worked
this you couldn't really do that and
it's all
pushing towards this end battle which is
also incredible
now one of the more interesting aspects
is actually steppenwolf
and i wasn't a big fan of him in the
original one even though i've got the
the funko pop back there wasn't a
massive fan of him but here you really
see
him in a sort of sympathetic light way
his pride
made him boast that he can destroy
worlds and take over planet
and because of that he's been cast out
of the the kingdom
of apocalypse and he's trying to win his
way back he gets a far
more fleshed out backstory he's a lot
more intimidating
and also a lot of his motives make more
sense for example
in the justice league cut he was just
showing up randomly on demascara
um showing up in atlantis and then he
was like well i don't know where the
human want to say well how how did you
find these other boxes
you see how he finds the boxes and you
also see
like why a lot of his motives make more
sense
there was another bit in justice league
where he teleports into where the
amazonians are
gets them other box they then lock him
in and it's just like well why would he
do that because he can clearly just
teleport in and out
no yeah they they do something totally
different that makes
it make a lot more sense and that in
general is the
the the overriding thing within the film
pretty much all of the plot holes
are filled in and everything just gels
together more and because of that you're
not sitting there going
well that doesn't make sense and it's
not taking you out of the movie as much
which for a four-hour film it needs to
grab your attention and keep you engaged
and this
really does things like the mother box
landing in the car park
that's taken out the russian family are
gone ka
put you you're off that is amazing that
they're removed
and even little touches like when ben
affleck was shaving on the plane
if you look at that you think ben
affleck looks like a totally different
geezer
he's probably just come off his holiday
to fill in this bit again
all the things like that that remove you
from the film are taken out and because
of that it feels a lot tighter and well
it's just better produced now much in
the same way that batman v
superman's ultimate edition added a lot
more context
and character motivation this film does
too
for example when bruce first meets
arthur arthur is pretty much like f
off i'm gonna go swim with some mermaids
and then for some reason he just
goes to atlantis anyway and decides to
get involved
here they add a scene in which you can
see why he has that motivation
and how it's almost calling back to his
destiny
and it works really well and there's so
many elements like that laced throughout
the film that
build upon these characters so you can
understand exactly what's driving them
now the biggest vindication in this
entire release outside of zach
is ray fish's performance as cyborg in
the original justice league version he
just felt like a robot you know he
wasn't
as interesting as he could be and he's
just sort of like i'm a monster and you
be
and you you were watching well uh what
can he really do
why is he that important does he need to
be here
this version he is the heart and soul of
this movie
and not only that they also make it
clear exactly
why he's one of the most powerful people
in the entire league
they have a scene where they show that
because he's interfaced with every
single aspect of technology on the
planet
that he is pretty much a god and can
control
all of our digital currency weapons
computer systems defense programs and
because of this he's the most powerful
person on earth
this is something that i never really
thought when when watching his portrayal
in justice league
and because it's fleshed out here you
almost see the gravity of the situation
on his shoulders and understand why this
is such a burden to him
now just supposing this the guy is also
half human so he has the
the the relationship with his father to
deal with and that feels
really well put across in this movie too
because of this
he's by far the mvp for me he's the most
interesting character in this film
and i think that there's a scene where
you sort of get his
his powers introduction and it feels
very similar to dr manhattan's in
watchmen where you can
sort of see his abilities and actually
it had me me shedding a tear at the end
of it because he does something very
very nice for a complete stranger
and i think when you watch it you're
gonna think wow this is
how they should have put the character
across and it will make you want that
solo movie with him
now that kind of motif carries across to
every single character and because of
that you get far more of their
motivation
and their thinking and saving the world
ezra miller's flash is another great
example of that
because we're not focusing on him gonna
i don't understand brunch what is brunch
he's like come on mate it's breakfast
and lunch
it's in the name what do you mean that's
not a quirky characteristic
however he does have these very very
good and light-hearted moments in this
movie where he just goes off rambling
talking very fast
and you understand because he's a
speedster he's sort of ahead of everyone
um thoughts wise so when he's going
through that it just makes the character
far more for you know better than him
just going i don't
understand breakfast and lunch together
so he's another performance that i feel
is really good um i've seen on social
media
there's a lot of people that dislike him
but
i think once you see his expanded power
set as well you start to really get
why he's gonna be important in the dc eu
going forward
now whether they stick with this or not
i don't know but after watching it
i think there's so many things that you
really want to see going forward
it's going to be difficult for warner
brothers to justify going in another
direction
after setting this up because those
cliffhangers at the ending
damn now have you've been keeping up
with the film you'll obviously have seen
that it ends on a cliffhanger
it doesn't just end on one cliffhanger
though it ends on quite a few
and even scenes like deathstroke meeting
lex on his yacht
they have some dialogue in that when you
watch it you will go
oh what and it basically just makes you
want to see that ben affleck
solo movie or hbo max show even more
because it is
so well done now this brings me to the
added material and though darkseid
isn't in the film all that much his
presence is felt a hell of a lot more
you get several flashes to the future
throughout this film and
every time he appears it's like oh
man kind of moment you will really crap
yourself at points when you see what
he's getting up to
now this kind of all builds towards the
nightmare scene which is
always in the back of batman's mind it's
not laced too heavily throughout the
film but there are several new moments
that no one has seen before
and they really flesh out why this guy
is being driven insane by his fear of
what's coming down the line
jared leto's joker also appears in this
and he steals the scene him and batman
have a brilliant exchange
in which you just think why has it taken
us this long to get a scene between
these two
it works really really well and you know
i was hoping for the we live in a
society line but that's not actually in
the movie so they just did a fun gag for
the trailer
but that scene is just outstanding and
it's one of the perfect ways to have the
pair interact
now superman on the whole he doesn't
actually get
that many more moments than what was in
the theatrical cut and he also shows up
quite late towards the end of the film i
think it's about the last hour that he
drops in
and you know if you were expecting a lot
more henry cavill unfortunately
that's not really here however i'd say
it's about the same amount of scenes
that was in the
the theatrical cut so you're not really
missing too much but the lines that he
gets in those scenes feel a lot more
poignant
for example him going back to the kent
farm that's got an added line of
dialogue that just
you know it gets in the heart strings
you see his future at points as well and
sort of understand
why he goes off in a certain direction
and it works really well
in fleshing him out beyond what we got
in the original
the original version which stupid face
that i'm
so glad was removed because i cannot
watch that film sometimes without being
taken out of it because of that
that terrible cgi which worst idea ever
the last hour is absolutely incredible
and from the point that clock gets
revived
they just constantly keep hitting you
with big moments
and it makes for an amazing climax and
beyond that you also get
about a 20-minute epilogue scene in
which a lot of things happen
and they set up so many interesting
pathways for the future that
if they don't go down this way yet i'm
showing up to
both both the warner brothers house i'm
saying no mate
you know we need this yeah so
cannot recommend it high enough not only
for what they've added but for what
they've also removed for example
aquaman just finding the the alien boxes
that's all taken out
the rooftop scene gone the the cell
phone scene gone the alien probe scene
gone the russian family
all those sort of aspects that really
made
the the first version terrible they're
gone
and in their place are so many amazing
moments that really build upon the
characters
show their motivations and also just
make this
you know the best the best dc eu film
that there is
and i know that's saying a lot but
you'll understand when you watch it this
is really hitting a home run
but that doesn't mean it's perfect yet
and we we are going to talk about the
bad now
i'm going to be objective here in my
review the film isn't perfect
and at four hours you're also going to
have some bits that don't work
however they are very very minor
so when when batman goes to meet arthur
for the first time there's
there's a weird yodeling scene in that
um that kind of goes on for for about a
minute
and uh yeah i i understand it's kind of
of
documenting the culture that the aquaman
was very much
integrated into but they just stand
there yodeling
and uh i was a bit like uh okay
this is this isn't that good there's
also the museum scene which is pretty
much
exactly the same as how it was presented
in the theatrical version
so the four city blocks bit and the
timer which
still makes no sense and that's all
still in it
and for me personally it doesn't really
work that well
now it's a good action scene at showing
off wonder woman but
when i look in there the grand scheme of
everything
it doesn't tie into the plot all that
much um all it really basically has
is a moment in which diana inspires a
young girl and that is a message that we
need but
in terms of is it necessary to the movie
no
and does it create logic problems when
you're watching it yes
so i don't really feel like the museum
scene works that well now because of
this there there are actually several
moments that i was
sure were joss whedon's but um actually
there's zack snyder's
and that that is basically the museum
scene
the first hour because it's it's using
you know the the foundation of the story
has to be the same
you you have to set up why steppenwolf
is coming you have to set up the way
that the world is after
what's happened with um superman's death
because of that
the first hour there will be moments
where you're like well i've already seen
this bit and
it's difficult to judge you um because i
i can't watch this with fresh eyes
without seeing
you know the justice league's always
going to be in the back of my mind
whenever i watch this film and because
of that this first hour is very much
sort of like oh you know is this this
could really go either way
um but once you get past that first hour
and they've got the foundations of the
story out the way that you
you've already seen before you realize
how much of a different direction
they're taking this in
and everything sort of builds towards
this amazing climax
the cemetery scenes also there which i
don't didn't really like
um and this cgi on a certain new
character
that we haven't seen before that you can
tell they didn't really have the time or
budget
to properly make them look amazing and
they don't look that good overall though
the museum scene that is my biggest
problem with the film
and you know in in the first in the
first version it was about
five to ten minutes of a two-hour movie
whereas he had
five to ten minutes of a four-hour movie
so the impact that it has
is negated come just massively um in
comparison
and the things i'm not sure on the
little nitpicks
the imax ratio i've watched the film
twice now
and i'm still a bit unsure on on how i
feel on that
i know everyone everyone in the comments
who's an expert on aspect ratios and
imacs are going to be arguing away going
well that's how it's meant to be filmed
personally you know to me when i'm
watching it i i'm thinking you've took
the
the black bars off the top and bottom
and you just put them on the sides
i know there's meant to be more of a
picture but when you watch it on a tv
it doesn't feel that way it just feels
like you've done that um
and that is something i'm still a bit
unsure of i probably prefer the way that
nolan presents imax which is that you
know you have your black bars along the
top and bottom on normal scenes but when
it's imax
it fills the full screen now what's also
interesting is that the theatrical cut
was also it also filled the screen
so it is quite strange that they've kind
of opted for this
this compressed version and personally i
i would just prefer the bars not to be
there so yeah argue argue away
um about how i don't know about aspect
ratios please
um i look i get the technical aspects i
get why
gemini man was shot in 120 frames per
second and then they
they had you know i can understand stuff
yeah it's just personal preference
i i i don't like the bars on the on the
left and right that much
doesn't ruin the film though it's a
nitpick now the score as well
that first hour i don't really feel like
the score was that strong
han zimmer did an incredible job with
man of steel and bbs to the point that i
i think his score
in those is absolutely incredible and it
really elevates the movie
now i know that jxl worked on batman v
superman as well and then he was given
this project to himself
and early on i don't really feel like
the the anthems are there
however as we get more into the film it
really starts to pick up
and by the end of it you are on board
with the work that he's done
but early on um first hour or so
i was thinking uh well i'm not you know
getting into the music as much as i
would be
nitpick again but yeah that's how i felt
now amber heard also has a weird british
accent in it and uh
i had to go back and rewatch justice
league which i hate you doing
to make sure that that she had an
american accent in that and she did
here she's got a british one which
clashes with aquaman as well i think i
don't know if i
haven't rewatched that but yeah it's
just kind of like uh
really okay um so yeah
don't don't know about the the accent
change don't know why they just
didn't say to her you've never done this
before amber
do it and what's weird is she actually
must have dubbed over her own scenes
with an american accent because one of
them is exactly the same
as how it was in the theatrical version
it just has a british accent over the
top
and we we all know british accents are
the most annoying things in the world
so yeah those are the nitpicks um
obviously the good was very
lots of stuff to talk about and lots of
stuff i couldn't talk about
the good just completely outweighs the
bad and the nitpicks and it makes for an
incredible film
this is really really brilliant you are
going to be sitting there at the end of
this thinking
why the hell did they go back and
reshoot 75
of this movie to give us what we got if
they hadn't released this
i think they would have by far been
probably
you know a lot further ahead than in the
marvel catch up
they might even be close to the same
point because they do such a good job of
introducing these characters as part of
the team
forming the team and setting up the
bigger threat down the line that really
makes you want to learn what happens
next
we definitely should get it and it's a
shame that justice league was released
because i know
a lot of people are going to see this
film and just say
oh well it's probably the same movie but
it's four hours long
oh that'll that'll put me off so word of
mouth is going to carry this film
as as does you know with a lot of zack
snyder's director's cut
batman v superman was very much a film
that i was like i don't like it in the
theater
watched it on the ultimate edition and
there was just improved it so much and
there was so many people that were like
well i thought it was crap in the
theater so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
bother with that and it's like
you have to say look mate you i'm
telling you you're sitting down although
i have
knocked you out and they go all right
mate you're a big tough guy i'll watch
it in the goal
at the end they go yeah you were right
and thanks for not beating me up as well
and i go i didn't promise i wouldn't
beat you up mate
um so yeah it just improves on it in
every single way
and you know i don't want to sound
disrespectful here so i'm going to
choose my words very
very very carefully and what happened
to to zach that made him leave this film
was a
complete tragedy now had he continued
working on the movie
the studio at some point would have
stepped in and said look you can't
release a four hour film in the theater
you just can't do it
and he would have had to have made some
compromises
so us getting this version it's the best
version that we could have got of this
movie i believe
i think if if they had released it in
theaters back in 2017
they would have had to have cut so much
and it wouldn't have been
as good as this is um so
that because zach's been allowed to have
full creative control on it
it's the best version of the film that
we could have got
and we were if we do if we never got
this version we would have been robbed
so in some ways to have it come out with
a four hour cut
it it's just vindicated this this
director who has been through
so much and this is this is gonna be
viewed as his masterpiece this will be
the film that he's remembered for
it's such an odyssey it's an epic and
it elevates snyder's reputation so much
and you see what he can do when he's got
full creative control
and he can make an absolutely
outstanding film which this definitely
is
now this film ends with the words for
autumn on the screen and it
it's such a you know it hits you you're
right in the fields
um and you realize how much this guy's
gone through and to just
have his version released which is so
good
it feels like true justice and that
that's not a terrible well it is a
terrible pun but i don't mean that in a
sort of mocking way
it's also got one of the classiest ads
that i've ever seen in the film
and you realize that zach was doing this
for his daughter
and it just feels you know even behind
the scenes stuff
it's as important as what we're seeing
on screen and the whole
story of how this film got made what
happened and now finally being released
there's so much going on in it and it it
lives up to the hype
it's hearts completely in the right
place it's the the best conclusion of
zack snyder's trilogy that we could hope
for
and warner bros are gonna have a
nightmare on their hands
come thursday crap pun intended on that
one
as this sets up so much for the future
that you will
that they could say anything's going to
be happening you know
um in the dc eu but if it hasn't got
these
people involved you're going to be like
well i kind of want to see that more so
do you mind do you mind going back and
getting them please
because it's just yeah a incredible um
and i can't wait to talk about it in the
spoilers i am going to score it
i'm going to score a 9 out of 10 and the
reason that i'm taking a point off is
purely
because of the the nitpicks i had um
such as the museum
scene the first hour because a lot of it
we have seen before even though it makes
more sense
um you are kind of going through the
motions with it at points
but beyond that incredible film
and uh you know i i i think people are
going to be hard-pressed
to say this is a bad movie you know
there's dc haters out there but
yeah we got everything we wanted and
everyone who's been
campaigning for this film since the
original
well done thank you for getting this
released um it's one of my favorite
comic book movies of all time
best dc eu film by far and
yeah what a conclusion to to an epic
trilogy
now thank you for sitting through my
rambling sorry i couldn't get into more
spoilers but i hope you enjoyed it
i've certainly enjoyed talking about it
and i can't wait to talk about it more
on thursday
um when i do an ending explained review
and talk about where things could be
going in the future
now if you enjoyed the video thumbs up
comments below there's quite a few
people that have actually seen that so
if they want to leave
reviews as well try and keep it spoiler
free yeah miner it's the miner spoilers
show
and i'd massively appreciate that and
yeah thank you for thank you for sitting
through my whole video
oh you have a good week uh if you
haven't seen it yet you will be having a
good week because come thursday
uh you're gonna absolutely love this
film and you take care of yourself
peace